Salut, aujourd'hui, je suis dans les loges du grand point Virgule
pour les hallucinations collectives et y a Karim Duval, qui n'est pas programmé
mais qui est passé.
D'ailleurs, tu viendras quand tu veux
F: Salut Karim,
K: Merci pour l'invitation
F: J'ai l'impression d'être Jean-Pierre Foucault
K: Jean-Pierre Fernault si tu nous écoutes
F: Jean-Pierre Fernault
K: Tu ne risques rien
F: J'ai beaucoup de chance que Karim il soit là parce que, il part au Maroc dans pas longtemps pour jouer.
Comment elle s'appelle cette grande salle où tu vas?
K: Megarama, y'a Mega dedans
F: Y'a Méga
K: C'est Méga date
F: C'est une méga date
Avec des mégas affiches d'ailleurs à Casablanca.
K: Tout est mega
Et Ça va être méga bien je pense
F: C'est ouf
K: ...Non je parle aux gens du bled là
F: Bon je vais y aller...
F: T' es Franco-Sino-Marocain c'est ça?
K: C'est ça jusque là c'est bon
F: Donc t'es un peu français, un peu marocain et un peu sino
K: Absolument c'est ça
il y a pas besoin de faire un schéma je pense
F: C'est par rapport au Chinois en fait
K: Cinois ouais
F: Cinois *rires*
F: J'ai cherché quelque chose qui s'appliquait le plus à toi.
J'ai pas trouvé de choses en chinois, mais j'ai trouvé par contre un recueil de poèmes japonais
K: C'est les petits proverbes c'est ça?
F: Voilà, c'est très court, c'est très épuré.
Si tu pouvais lire le 1er.
K: Ok le 2ème peut-être parce que le 1er est en japonais
F: Le 1er il est en japonais mais t'as les traductions après, je vous le fait voir
"Parfum d'une chevelure qui nous submerge'
Voilà c'est très court, c'est toujours des sensations.
K: On cherche toujours le verbe dans ce genre de vers par contre.
F: C'est vrai.
F: "De son nénuphar, la grenouille saute d'un gros nuage" c'est joli ça !
K: Là il y a un sujet, verbe, complément et ça me plait
F: *Rires*
K: Je vois pas le sens par contre
F: Le sens? Ah bah attend.
K: Pour l'appliquer à la vie en fait.
F: Ah ben si ça veut dire que par exemple des fois tu peux te leurrer en fait.
Tu crois que le ciel il est à ta portée et en fait c'est le reflet de ciel dans l'eau.
K: C'est vrai, je suis vraiment 1er degrés
F: Et du coup, elle saute, elle veut sauter et elle veut atteindre un objectif trop haut et elle tombe dans l'eau en fait.
Donc il faut peut être régler le... enfin chacun interprète comme il veut hein !
K: Ok, en fait c'est un peu moi qui a envie de faire un megarama et qui...
K: Et qui... trop trop envie et qui espère ne pas être trop  dans la plaque?
F: En fait, tu va te retrouver au Chinchman
K: En fait, je suis le Chinchman et un grand bonjour à Françoise Deldick, parce que c'est une des meilleurs scène ouverte de Paris.
F: Grave
K: On t'embrasse Françoise
F: Tu vas ouvrir sur la page que tu veux, tu vas lire ton poème.
F: Tu lis de manière à ce que je puisse pas voir mais on va voir comme ça dans la GoPro en temps réel.
F: Les gens ils pourront voir quand je ferai le montage après.
K: C'est génial ces vidéos
F: Ok donc tu le lis
F: C'est bon t'en a un en tête?
K: C'est tellement dur à retenir
F: Cale avec un doigt ou quelque part sinon
K: C'est bon
F: C'est bon ok
F: On a vu comme avec la grenouille, le nuage ce genre de chose on peut visualiser ces scènes là en temps normal.
On peut s'imaginer les cheveux, on peut s'imaginer la grenouille, le nuage, la flaque.
Est ce que toi ton poème tu peux te le représenter en terme d'images mentalement?
K: Oui
F: Oui, alors tu vas te représenter ces images là dans ta tête.
K: D'accord
F: Et je vais essayer moi de symboliser ça, de dessiner ça, ça marche?
K: D'accord ça marche
F: Ok, t'es déjà aller chercher des choses en hauteur donc je suppose qu'il y a vraiment un haut, un ciel, et un bas, dans ces cas là.
K: Ouais
F: [en riant] Oh ça t'agaces ça.
K: Ça m'énerve
F: Ok maintenant reste à savoir, si c'est le jour, la nuit ce genre de chose. Et apparement c'est plus la nuit
Un truc comme ça
K: [en langue étrangère] C'est le diable
F: Je suis sûr qu'en espagnol on dit El Diablo, sur ce que tu viens de dire
K: Non en espagnol on dit: "Mis minar manar a la jim"
K: Mais il y a le diablo dedans
F: Ah oui ça c'est sur
K: Tu le dis quand le diablo est là
F: Euh... je pense avoir le haut, essaie de bien te représenter ce qu'il se passe en bas
F: Tu le re-regardes c'est ça?
K: Oui je veux bien
F: Ok je retourne la tête, tu me dis quand c'est bon
K: C'est bon
F: C'est bon là tu t'imagines ce qui il y en bas
F: Est ce que tu peux imaginer ton dessin ce que tu te représente mentalement devant moi et bouger tes yeux pour re-sculpter tout ce qu'il y a
K: Ok
F: D'accord, tac, tac, taaac. Ah peut-être que
écoute je vais faire un dessin comme ça, je dessine extrêmement mal, on l'a déjà vu dans d'autres vidéos d'ailleurs.
F: Ok j'ai un dessin, je le changerai plus
F: Regarde par là, parce que je vais leur faire voir à l'écran et je ne veux pas que tu puisse... Non regarde ici
Je vais leur faire voir et je ne veux pas que tu puisses toi voir ce que j'ai mis. Voilà ce que j'ai mis moi chut
F: Est ce que tu peux nous lire ton poème maintenant
K: "La lune flotte au dessus du cercle des danseurs"
F: Alors je dessine comme je peux mais j'ai dessiné la lune qui flotte au dessus d'un cercle de danseurs
K: Génial
F: Fais voir
K: Et il a mis l'étoile du Maroc en plus
F: J'ai mis l'étoile du Maroc et si on suit la route on peut aller au Gigarama
K: Méga Giga c'est pour euh
F: Ah oui Méga
K: Giga c'est pour le lendemain
F: Alors, on peut, je vous fais voir, si il y en a qui se pose la question après c'était:
L'abeille ouvrière rejoint la fleur prometteuse et fertile
pour lequel ce dessin n'aurait pas marcher du tout, évidemment !
K: Bien sûr que je suis bluffé, je suis tout le temps bluffé, même quand je te dis bonjour je suis bluffé
*Rires*
K: Je te jure, parce que je sais que tu vas me dire bonjour
F: Et à chaque fois je reconnais ton prénom...
K: Tout le temps, tous les jours à chaque fois et ça jusqu'à là ce tout là je le maîtrise aussi, assez bien.
K: Salut Karim ça va?
F: J'aimerai tellement venir te voir au Maroc mon pote
K: Ben vient, vient si tu veux, vient faire une vidéo là bas
F: P**tain c'est bon ça
K: Tu viens me mentaliser
F: Ben oui
F: Faut que je trouve un budget... Vlog au Maroc
K: Et bien on va se cotiser
F: C'est le 3 mars c'est ça ?
K: On va se cotiser pour Fabien Olicard et je prie pour que Fabien, il vienne jouer chez vous au Maroc. Il va tous vous bluffer, il est énorme !
Venez le voir.
F: Je joue en Algérie moi bientôt.
K: En Algérie, ben écoute pourquoi tu tournes pas au Maroc ?
F: Pour l'Algé'rire.
K: Ah pour Algé'rire, très beau festival aussi.
F: D'ailleurs, rejoignez Karim sur son Facebook, sur son site internet il y a toutes les infos et il va sortir des vidéos dans pas très longtemps.
J'ai vu les rushs, enfin j'ai lu le titre, enfin il m'a parlé du concept
F: Et vraiment j'ai hâte de voir ça parce que ça va être cool.
K: Et on en a dit vachement au gens à propos des vidéos.
F: C'est vrai
K: C'est cool, comme ça tu as donné toute l'information
S'ils sont un peu mentaliste, si ils suivent ton Vlog et qu'ils écoutent tes conseils peut être qu'ils arriveront à deviner de quoi parle mes vidéos.
F: Bien sûr, imagine c'est facile
F: Non je leur dis pas moi
K: Évidence
F: Je leur dis ou pas?
K: Non non surtout pas
F: Pensez à vous abonner. Abonnez vous à cette chaîne YouTube, c'est hyper important, vous pouvez partager la vidéo !
Et n'oubliez pas l'objectif à 2500 abonnés, on se fait un apéro virtuel tous ensemble.
Et rendez vous demain à 11h pour le prochain MentalVlog.
Ciao !